qu'ils sont les gagnants et les perdants
des audiences alors j'ai l'impression
qu'on va encore se répéter bah oui parce
que des fois nos amis de tf1 ils sont
encore arrivé troisième de la soirée
premier de la soirée hier le meilleur
pâtissier m6 bah oui leader les
audiences est vrai comme point on peut
faire des éclairs et de religieuses
arrivé numéro 1 des zones ans voilà bah
moi je suis un moelleux au chocolat
j'arrive quatrième les chéris nos
diables au coeur france 2 j'adore
magnifique c'est magnifique c'est vrai
c'était quoi
sam exemple téléfilm sera une femme qui
se fait avoir par un petit jeune et ça
va détruire ses ennemis le film avec
gérard philipe à l'époque exact oui
c'est vrai c'est une resucée si j'ose
dire du diable au corps
bien sûr je sais le diable au corps le
diable au coeur et grain à moudre
exactement 20 heures c'est quoi une
resucée will rodman et un film c'est
quand on vole on a vu un film est en
fait on fait une adaptation bercy zahia
comme moi qui vous comprend on est fait
pour le septième art les cherry on va
voir donc les gagnants et les perdants
d'hier soir y'avait faut pas rêver sur
france 3 ouest notes tellement souvent
ce n'est pas non plus la peine de nous
lire et à la vraie histoire de queen sur
tmc
moi j'avais adoré j'ai ben là
franchement d'ailleurs c'était ça qui
m'avait donné envie à l'époque de fer
freddie mercury en début d'émission s'en
souvient j'avais pas regardé le film de
barback ou pas
hier soir du côté des audiences télé les
chaînes étaient au coude à coude côté
téléspectateurs et part d'audience
on peut dire que ça s'est joué dans un
mouchoir de poche c'est quoi c'est cool
c'est m6 qui domina soirée qui arrive en
tête avec son rendez vous du jeudi soir
le meilleur pâtissier qui attire et 15,5
pour cent du public soit 3 millions
176000 gourmand crocs sur la deuxième
place du podium on retrouve france 2 qui
a réuni trois millions cent
cinquante-huit mille téléspectateurs
soit 13 5% du public devant son film le
diable au coeur avec zabou breitman
c'est génial
tf1 quant à elle arrive une nouvelle
fois en bas du podium avec sa série en
deux épisodes new amsterdam avec 13 8 3%
de pda et 3 millions téléspectateurs
j'ai horreur d'arrivée le dernier tmc de
son côté a performé avec la diffusion du
documentaire bohemian rhapsody la vraie
histoire de queen qui a attiré un
million de curieux sa synchro mais une
fois encore avec ses audiences qu'on
s'aperçoit que tf1 de plus en plus de
mal à affirmer sa place de leader sur la
case des prime m6 et france 2 relève une
nouvelle fois la première chaîne un cas
de figure qui semble se reproduire de
plus en plus souvent notamment face au
programme novateur du service public
alors le groupe france télévisions est
il en train de manger tf1 alors nicolas
pernikoff accueilli non non non la
question c'est froid alors je veux dire
la vérité en plus et je le dis et j'ai
rien contre eux font traîner vient de
coupe mais moi par exemple je regarde
plus les prime de tf1 que de france 2
wesh dit la vérité et je le dis même
s'il faut que je me fasse des ennemis
mais je dis la vérité voilà ça dépend
sur france 3 au niveau de la finition
c'est vrai qu'ils ont gagné il gagne à
chaque fois les 4 ans et plus donc c'est
très très large exact ce qui se passe
par contre c'est qu'il ya un vrai
phénomène qui est en train de se
produire c'est le phénomène m6 sur les
responsables des achats à dire les moins
de 50 ans y va menait face à tf1 qui est
vraiment là la cible publicitaire
stratégique
je vais clichés le téléspectateur en
fait ce qui se passe et c'est vrai qu'il
ya des pubs pour nous les émissions et
ses pubs
elles ont besoin d'avoir un public
captif et ceux qui consomment le plus ce
sont dix autres sont les 25 49 look
c'est vraiment les cibles prioritaires
et les femmes de moins de 50 ans et
c'est vrai que moi je me rappelle quand
j'étais m6 ont raconté moi je vais chez
ish effet six mois m6 et y regarder même
pas le chiffre global c'est-à-dire qu'on
vous dise on fait tout ça il regarde
juste la part d'audience qu'on a fait
les 25 49 ou sur les femmes de moins de
50 ans voilà si vous avez fait part et
11,25 c'est une super audience à la tf1
ils doivent pas être en dessous de 30
normalement à 30 à la cci et vous paraît
une époque où tf1 était à 45 exactement
50 c c'est à dire la moitié c'est sacré
lui ado puis sont plus ils sont là
dessus mais celui qui vendent des plus
chers et puis ça le rapport de leur
langue s'exhale reste quand même une
entreprise une chaîne de terreur oui
donc hier on parlait de ddt programme de
f1 manière des programmes de m6 au jour
lui qui sont entre 9 et 15 saisons vous
allez top chef l'amour est dans le pré
et incroyable talent aujourd'hui
surperforme c'était parti mais pire
encore c'est l'information c'est lui 19
45 de m6 aujourd'hui carte au pied de
leader par rapport au 20 heures de tf1
et ça c'est un événement bref vous
regardez hier soir le 19 45 points à 3 3
celui tf1 le 20 heures à fait vain -
c'est incroyable ça c'est un cataclysme
c'est un cataclysme scénario c'est un
cataclysme oui mais c'est logique et de
laura dire mais c'est vrai logique parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a plus tendance à
vouloir regarder quelque chose de de
condensé de rapides moi le premier je
préfère regarder les yeux 45 ces photos
on a toutes les infos this much as
regardé benjamin castaldi tout nu c'est
comme ça va décompresser mais efficace à
la moisson leslie tranche stratégique et
c'est pas parce que parce que je suis
pour rien
je pense que m6 taille plus des
croupières à tf1 que france télévisions
est exactement mais même si je fait plus
peur à tf1 que france télé mine de rien
parce que c'est vrai qu'ils sont plus
ménagères comme on dit je pense qu'il
faut la question tout de suite de savoir
qui incarne m6 vous allez me répondre
stéphane plaza sur m6 lors des week-ends
tf1 et m6 aujourd'hui aux policiers
étaient quasiment cinq six personnes en
plus
oui mais attention aux m6 il et les
programmes sont très incarnée elle vous
avez eric en douane qui est venu sur le
plateau hier vous avez effectué en plein
air où les autres tandis que et et en
plus ya cette diversification m6 qui est
très importante avec les agences
immobilières stéphane plaza cyril lignac
est tout ce qu'il ya autour ça rapporte
de l'argent les et un moment donné pour
m6 un scanner mais la moitié des revenus
il s'associe avec stéphane 6 25%
stéphane c'est exact c'est normal et un
pourcentage qui la suit pas souligner
j'ai envie de me placer alors non pas en
tant que chroniqueuse ni en tant que
cible je me dis je suis téléspectatrices
je regarde mon journal télé voyons ce
que je vais pouvoir consommer alors je
regarde lundi prochain coup de foudre à
noël ce sera la troisième diffusion sur
tf1 depuis 2010 est très liée à la merci
slash oui même si c'est ton merci c'est
pour en des comptes depuis 2010 est
c'est la troisième diffusion la semaine
dernière
coup de foudre sur un air de noël
deuxième diffusion mardi prochain round
2 mercredi
non mais c'est vrai qu'on prend dans
sept autres x men et ensuite il nous
place new amsterdam face à l'ajax hugo
on on peut saluer l'ex hugo qui va
cartonner encore alexis l'anif même ont
redit alors les rediff par chimio sur
prouvez moi pourquoi l'hérault dif et je
le pose la question et je pourquoi les
reliques marche mais sur france 2 france
3 sur tf1
parce que moi je sais la réponse vois
pourquoi les et parce que ce sont des
héros français que le public adore
que ce soit alex hugo que ce soit marc
loos one et moi elle l'a fait lors dé
mam c'est l'inversé français qu'il
faudra oui mais est toutefois c'est vrai
mais ça va peut-être marcher parce que
là non mais non mais non pas on passe
maintenant 205 par exemple ça marche pas
parce que les séries américaines et ils
sont pas identifiés les roues non mais
là c'est qu'aulas parce que là c'est la
samare pas son truc à is able qui j'ai
jamais d'avoir d'abord vous avez une
audience beaucoup plus vigilantes sur
france 3 ce soir première chose et après
de l'autre côté il ya toujours où il pas
ce qu'on appelle un torrent télé lyon un
taux de du pli très dangereux vocation
quoi vérifications très dangereux pour
tf1 qui a toujours été france 3
bizarrement ah ouais c'est à dire que de
temps en temps france 3 super forme
rarement mais sûrement sur certaines
cibles par la droite et femmes c'est ben
ouais franchement là on est dans les
médias foule ça peut être cette émission
duplication lorsque vous intéresser aux
fictions de france télévisions lorsqu'on
vernet les cibles par exemple des
fictions de françois elles font appel 5
à 7% sur les fameux les responsables des
achats de moins de 50 ans donc premier
envoi de pub france 2 france 3 sur les
vols de la puissance je suis d'accord et
la puissance elle ne la trouve pas sur
les spéciales américaines on vous en
parlait hier new amsterdam typiquement
mais en matière de rentabilité
il est peut-être plus rentable d'acheter
une série américaine que d'investir dans
l'opération
mais non ce qu'on pense régine qui était
en marche à pied tf1 il faut savoir qu'à
l'époque de tf1 dès qu'une émission
marchait pas trop en prime time il a
déprogrammé moi je sois paru en 2006 le
royaume ça faisait 3 millions et bien
sûr des programmations direct paris viii
pour 2011 j'ai fait un petit tableau
échec d'audience déprogrammation au bout
de deux semaines en 2014
the dancers déprogrammation au bout de
cinq jours et la nieuw amsterdam sa
fille depuis un an plus d'un an que
c'est à l'antenne il le laisse toujours
alors c'est des sports qui sont au nord
simon fait 3100 blessés fesci refaire
exactement c'est un tableau mais bien
sûr je vais entamer chez vous pour
l'émission nord pour l'émission bat la
mer et oui et puis si le but pour eux
pas bravo pour la régie commerce et
[Rires]
n'importe quoi voilà voilà
ouais voilà donc oui mais voilà c'est
tout moi c'était pour mettre ça c'était
s'est pas non plus bouffonne et a pu
alors et donc si le but c'est d'attirer
les femmes les jeunes femmes et les
femmes ben moi personnellement je
préfère regarder les pâtissiers plutôt
qu'une série une série ou satire ou
c'est un truc un ami mais août après un
accès plus violents voilà c'est ça ben
les pâtissiers c'est beau elle voyait
dans des souliers voyez le pouf une
forêt noire mois s'était révélée
progresse pas cyril pourquoi par exemple
quand ils voient que retour vers le
futur qui est un film indémodable ok
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne déprogramme
pas quand même règle il ya une règle
pour des programmes et il faut que ça
fasse 20% de moins que la deuxième sur
cible que la semaine d'avant vous
intéresser en fait non là ils sont pas
20 % neymar parce que voyez donc qu'il
peut ils n'ont pas droit des programmes
et notre ongles non merci voilà le baril
et en plus si l'une des séries qui ont
été coupées 1-2 cause du confinement
dons qu'ils écluses il termine les trucs
dit oui et pour répondre à la question
écrite alors pourquoi françois marchal
mis au rugby parce qu'ils avaient
absolue tony fin des séries
feuilletonnantes avec des personnages
qui reviennent alors que tf1 c'est des
téléfilms unitaires dont convient de
s'attacher aux personnages à sur wii le
dernier truc c'est que aujourd'hui on
s'attache à une marque donc aujourd'hui
une télévision se fâche c'est un
programme c'est un univers vous avez un
univers sur ces 8 avec vous vous avez un
univers aujourd'hui sur la glace dès
l'hiver avec les bios la personne qui
incarne m6 oui et vous êtes attachés à
une marque france 3 si elles sont les
régions
énormément de charme et la proximité
mais c'est surtout l'exadata quand on
vole leur fougue à dire une chose c'est
que aujourd'hui en puissance en télé tu
n'as pas les les vieux pour parler
vulgairement on n'avait pas de puissance
donc il préfère avoir moins de vieux
mais faire effectivement sur les cibles
un meilleur score parce qu'il fait de
france 3 c'est catastrophique il n'y a
que des villes michel et pourrait dans
cette vision est il en train de manger
tf1 bas si on se concentre juste sur le
mois de novembre
gouffran saivet ses 28 7% de part
d'audience le groupe tf1 ces 27 d'agde
8% ce qui signifie ce qui signifie
qu'aucun autre illusion est beaucoup
plus fort en matière web leur démarche
et oui c'est lui et moi c'est vrai
patron préparer parce que france
télévisions ils ont deux chaînes
hertziennes étaient bons pour des ventes
des vins pour le coup tf1 ils ont deux
chaînes de la tnt tf1 alors de france où
ils ont de grosses chaînes france 2 et
france 3 donc en puissance est normal
qu'ils soient plus petits riens oui car
il m'a regardé avec ces partis à 33%